her name's nirvana alana she goes by  alana because  tsa was doing a thing where they were  purchasing dogs and adding hyphenated  names in order to honor 9 11 victim she  was named after alana abraham who was a  9 11 victim who died on the boston  flight  every year tsa has the cutest k9  competition just to kind of like you  know promote the k9 program and the  agency and she's quite sassy if you see  her walk she's very wiggly and she also  loves to say hi to like all the other  handlers she's excited to see people so  she's just like overall a very friendly  dog  very social and like a really good  worker who doesn't love a golden  retriever it's america's favorite dog